hey man you already know what's your boy
pamby rock you bout to check out my 10
essentials with gq
oh yeah that way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is gonna be my first ascension
right here you know i'm saying the big
deal or bag
you know
not the little one
yeah a lot of stuff is in here it's like
pretty much my essentials i ain't gonna
cap you know i switch my bags up every
now and then just to match my drip so i
take all of this stuff out and put it in
another bag i would say this is my
favorite bag because it's my newest bag
and i always be liking the new drip more
than i like my old stuff for some reason
let me see what we got up in here man
one
so you gotta have your wallet you know
what i'm saying can't go nowhere without
it gotta have my debit cards you know
what i'm saying up here i got my my
passport id
you know we got the
the express card you know i'm saying the
big boy don't play with him i like to
keep my little two dollar bills in old
20s and 50s and stuff like that
yeah that's pretty much it what's in the
wallet you know a whole bunch of random
cards and
the wallet is a louis vuitton while it
is like a royal blue type of vibe i had
this for a while my girl brought this
for me i once said she bought it for me
for my last birthday or last father's
day one of them
shout out to bae for the louis drip
that way
nah i ain't gonna lie it's too big for
me i can't sit on it it's like
uncomfortable to sit on the bottom this
this big
it feels like a little car holder maybe
but no this is two i put it in the bag
my third essentially gonna be that lay
lava i like to move around with
different fragrances one of my newer
fragrances that i just got put on my
bait put me on this pretty much it's
cool because
like when you when you're getting it
made you facetime me like they literally
like making it in front of your face
like there's not nothing that you're
just gonna buy out of a store they
literally making this in front of your
face and it's like real personalized
like on my bottle
bay wrote on there rock big daddy energy
no kids yeah but it's a good fragrance
and stick with you all day this right
here is number 25 you know what i'm
saying
they got different levels levels
for my fourth
you already know me i'm coming ice man i
don't go nowhere without the chain i'm
going nowhere without the braces the
broly the cardi the skelly the rings you
know this is part of my image just part
of my look so when you see me you're
gonna always see me busting
you can see me from far away in the dark
time because my my [ __ ] bust you heard
me no kissy spent a lot of money on this
um
and there's not no investments i don't
look at it like i'm trying to get my
money back when i spend money i don't
look it to get money back i just look at
it as a loss i lost the money i spent it
it's gone i'm not one of those people
that'd be like oh this gotta you put
diamonds in it so it's gonna depreciate
like
no i spent the money so it's gone and
you feel me that's just how i am and i
just feel like i'ma always make money
i'm always gonna catch my blessings from
blessing other people you know what i'm
saying so i don't look at nothing like
it's a
i can get it away and just buy new you
feel me that's how i feel but i love my
jewelry i got a lot more than what you
see right now but
it's a way right now
you're gonna see some more of that ice
coming soon
oh yeah
that way
right now my favorite piece gonna be
this roller right here with the pink
emeralds all in that month this is my
newest piece i'll just be hype i'm like
a hypebeast when i get some news i'll be
hyped about that new thing like so when
i get another piece it's probably gonna
be my favorite piece that's just hobby
moving
i got a a new lane chain that's my
company i got a new lane chain i don't
got it on me right now but that's one of
the i had that since like 2018
and that's when i really started copying
jewelry i think that's my first biggest
piece i spent like 50 bands on it so i
ain't never gonna let that one go i'm
keeping it forever that's just like my
one of those pieces like i'm gonna keep
that i might give it to my son when i
have a son or something you know what
i'm saying one of them type vibes
my fifth essentials i know everybody
know you got to keep your phones in
philly we call these the jack got to
keep my jack um i got two phones
because like one is like
a newer phone i'm trying to get rid of
my old number but there's so many people
that got this number like people in jail
people like like my old family members
like that just won't
they don't want to convert over to the
new number but
it's getting there you know i got two
phones though yeah team two phones my
fifth essential
it's gonna be these chrome hearts i got
some chrome hearts on right now but
these like my favorite glasses like if
you see me you always see me with some
type of different specs and different
frames i switch it up all the time like
chrome hearts is like one of my favorite
glasses
like they're real intricate they be
having like real gold real like platinum
on it and not too many people you're
going to see with them neither
yeah these are i just got these these
are new pickups
all right
1300 no kizzy chrome heavy
put these bad boys on show you how he's
coming man
boom
gq you know
i'm coming clear chromie today though
that's how i feel that's my vibe people
always think i got the same glasses on
because i wear like a typical like clear
frame
i'm not blind enough and i really could
see 20 20 it's just like i just like
this is my look right here you know what
i'm saying like i'm coming glasses man
coming chrome heart glasses these ones
right here is real small they got the
platinum on the side
huh
i don't think this is platinum xl it
might tell you what it is because they
tell you like on the top
yeah 925 is silver i think that's silver
0.925
yeah they'd be coming with real heavy
artillery
i've been rocking glasses for a long
time i don't i want to say probably like
12 000 seven i used to rock ray-bans
heavy because i used to be like
like an all-nighter i used to be up all
night and i used to like have bags under
my eyes and i really want people to see
them so i should just cover it up with
the glasses now i'm just like it's my
look now my seventh essential i gotta
come iphone charger you know what i'm
saying i'm coming iphone charge
especially this on the usb c one
man you don't know how many i don't
probably brought like 50 of these so far
since they've been out just because
people still need so fast like a person
that still doesn't don't think they
stole nothing they sit there and tell
you they ain't still nothing danny like
whole time they know they didn't stole
your charger we know kizzy this is real
essential to me because you know my
phone i got two phones and they always
be dying i always be on my phone i'm
always on my phone 24 7. everything that
come through pmb come to the jack come
to the phone so
yeah i need my charger don't touch my
charger i'm not trying to put no
markings on it and none of that and make
you know it's mine just don't touch it
you feel me
hey man my eighth essential is my
lighter you know the big one can't come
crack here lighter than that we call
them piper strikers but this right here
i need my ladder everywhere i go because
if you know me you know i need the
lighter quaint blank
i used to be one of them balls
that had like
the lighter with the clip on my pants
because lighter is like lighter and
charger is like top two things that
people are going to steal from you and
act like they didn't steal nothing from
you they're going to look you're going
to you're going to run across your
lighter with your friends at least three
or four of them are going to have your
lighter and they pocket and just act
like it's normal for them to have it
this ain't your lighter bro give me my
life
my ninth essential no i'm a rapper so
just in case i just want to flex one day
you know i'm saying
i might want to go to the strip club or
something like that
i might just want to be generous and
just bless somebody you know what i'm
saying
got to have them wrecks
yeah i ain't gonna lie sometimes i go
this is why i'll be having cash some
people be like why you got cars why you
got cash a lot of times i'll be
traveling around
and my car declined on some rare [ __ ]
because like i'm just traveling and i
haven't told my bank that i'm here
and i ain't got time for this i'm coming
cash you feel me we can go one way or
another way or decline
let me go in the bag real quick
think about nothing you hear me at least
got at least 10 to 15 on me if i'm
spending more than that
then but i'm cool at least 10 to 15
right you know what i'm saying
yeah that's easy
the racks
and my last essential my 10th essential
i'ma come passport because you know what
i'm saying like i gotta keep this with
me because i'm like a real spontaneous
person so if i ain't really got nothing
to do
i don't really like just sticking around
and being bored so i might just hop on a
flight just to go to jamaica go to
puerto rico and you don't got to be in
the united states but i go somewhere man
you know what i'm saying take my base
and run so i keep my passport with me
too
i went to guam
that was probably the last place i went
before i was started getting crazy he
was moving around
hey man you already know it's your boy
pamby rock and you just checked out my
10 essentials with gq
oil that way